>> Jason: WELCOME BACK TO
THIS SPECIAL EDITION OF
"HANNITY."
TRUMP'S BIG WEEK.
WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONTINUES TO MAKE HUGE FOREIGN
POLICY GAINS IN THE KOREAN
PENINSULA AND BEYOND, THE
MUELLER WITCH HUNT CONTINUES
AT HOME.
KIM STRASSEL AT THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" IS OUT WITH A
BOMBSHELL NEW PIECE TITLED
"WHAT ABOUT THAT F.B.I.
SOURCE: DID THE BUREAU ENGAGE
IN OUTRIGHT SPYING AGAINST THE
2016 TRUMP CAMPAIGN?"
JOINING ME NOW TO EXPLAIN MORE
FROM THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE PIECE KIM
STRASSEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
GIVE US A QUICK SENAP ANALYSIS
OF WHAT YOU -- SYNOPSIS OF
WHAT YOU FOUND AND WHY THIS IS
UNUSUAL IN THIS SETTING.
>> UP UNTIL LAST WEEK ALL WE
KNEW WAS HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES HAD A NEW
LINE OF INQUIRY AND WAS
DEMANDING NEW DOCUMENTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IN THEIR DESIRE TO MAKE
CHAIRMAN NUNES LOOK BAD, AND
JUSTIFY WHY THEY WERE NOT
GIVING THOSE DOCUMENTS,
SOMEONE IN THE GOVERNMENT
LEAKED A LOT OF DETAILS ABOUT
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
IT TURNS OUT HE IS ASKING
ABOUT A TOP SECRET GOVERNMENT
SOURCE WHO HAS WORKED FOR THE
F.B.I. AND THE C.I.A.
WHO IS A U.S. CITIZEN.
WOULD SEEM TO HAVE SOME SORT
OF ENTANGLEMENT WITH THE
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
OR MAYBE HIS BASE OVERSEAS.
BASED ON ALL OF THOSE BREAD
CRUMBS AND SOME REPORTING,
I'VE GOT A PRETTY GOOD SENSE
OF WHO IT IS.
IT DOES LOOK AS THOUGH INDEED
THERE WAS AN F.B.I. ATTEMPT, A
SUCCESSFUL ONE TO BASICALLY GO
OUT AND SPY WITH A HUMAN ASSET
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Jason: WHAT ABOUT THE
TIMING IN IS THE TIMING ABOUT
ALL OF THIS IS CRITICAL.
DO WE UNDERSTAND THE TIMING?
WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS FOR
THAT?
>> YEAH.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
REMEMBER THE F.B.I. HAS BEEN
DOGGEDLY STICKING WITH THIS
STORY THAT WHAT INITIATED THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PROBE WAS
A TIP THEY GOT IN JULY ABOUT
THIS SUPPOSED DRUNKEN
CONVERSATION OF A JUNIOR
CAMPAIGN AID NAMED GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
IF FOR ANY REASON WE FIND OUT
THAT THIS PERSON, THIS ASSET
OF THEIRS WAS, IN FACT,
SURVEILLING OR SPYING ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN PRIOR TO THAT
TIME, THEN THEY'VE GOT AN
ISSUE, RIGHT?
THAT IS NO LONGER THEIR ORIGIN
STORY AND THERE MUST HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING ELSE THEY BASED THIS
ON.
WHETHER IT BE THE DOSSIER OR
SOME INFORMATION THEY USED AS
A REASON TO SURVEIL THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> Jason: HOW ARE WE GOING
TO FIGURE OUT THE SOLUTION TO
THIS?
EVERY TIME THAT TREY GOWDY,
DEVIN NUNES AND OTHER GOES TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THEY
GET THE STIFF ARM, EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE SUBPOENAS IN PLACE.
HOW DO THEY FIGURE THIS OUT?
>> WE HAVE A GREAT PIECE IN
THE "JOURNAL" TODAY BY A
FORMAL F.B.I. OFFICER JUST
TALKING AND HIS JOB WAS TO
FULFILL CONGRESSIONAL
REQUESTS.
TALKING ABOUT HOW OBNOXIOUS
AND OUTRAGEOUS IT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS NOT
COMPLYING WITH SIMPLE REQUESTS
AND SUBPOENAS FROM CONGRESS.
THE FACT THEY DIDN'T GIVE THE
INFORMATION OVER TO CHAIRMAN
NUNES ALL THE WAY LAST YEAR
WHEN HE SAID HE WAS
INVESTIGATING THE F.B.I.'S
CONDUCT IS PRETTY STRIKING.
THEY ARE GOING TO CONGRESS AS
A BODY AND THE GOOD NEWS IS
CHAIRMAN NUNES LOOKS TO HAVE
THE BACKING OF ALL THE
LEADERSHIP AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
MAKE IT CLEAR IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DOES NOT
TURN THIS OVER THEY WILL MOVE
TO CONTEMPT.
WITH ANY LUCK THE WHITE HOUSE
IS PUTTING OUT A MESSAGE THEY
NEED TO COOPERATE AND HAND
OVER DOCUMENTS.
>> Jason: I THOUGHT THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS BACKING UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AT THIS
POINT, WEREN'T THEY?
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE MADE
A BIG DEAL IN THE LETTER TO
CHAIRMAN NUNES ABOUT HOW IT
HAD, THIS HAD ALL BEEN DONE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE.
CURIOUSLY IT DID AGREE TO SIT
DOWN WITH CHAIRMAN NUNES.
PROBABLY THEY HAVE THE ORDER
TO ACCOMMODATE HIM IN SOME
WAY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IT
WITHOUT HANDING OVER THE
ACTUAL DOCUMENTS BUT IF THAT
IS WHAT NUNES AND OTHERS ARE
AFTER, IT SEEMS IT'S WHAT THEY
HAVE TO HAND OVER TO FULFILL
THE REQUEST.
>> Jason: AS ONE WHO HAS
BEEN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND SAT IN THE MEANING
AND LISTEN TO THE BLOW-HARDS
TELL ME HOW CONGRESS HAS NO
RIGHT TO SEE THIS STUFF.
IT IS OFFENSIVE.
AT WHAT POINT DOES THE
CONSTITUTION COME INTO PLAY?
THEY GIVE LIP SERVICE TO
OVERSIGHT BUT THEY ARE
LEAKING -- IT'S PRETTY WELL
DOCUMENTED THAT THEY ARE
LEAKING.
WHAT IS IT THEY THINK THEY
CAN'T AND SHOULDN'T SO TO
CONGRESS, WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> LOOK, YOU KNOW THIS BETTER
THAN ANYONE.
WE HAVE PROCESSES IN PLACE
WHEREBY CONGRESS GETS TO
OVERSEE THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THEY CAN'T JUST SAY GIVE US
EVERYTHING.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE SPECIFIC
CAUSE, REASON, THINGS THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR.
AS THIS PIECE WE RAN TODAY
MADE CLEAR WHEN THE CASES CAME
UP, THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS ALWAYS HELPED AND BEEN
GOOD ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE PROCESSES WHEREBY IN
PARTICULAR THE GANG OF EIGHT,
RIGHT?
>> Jason: YEAH.
>> THE SENIOR MEMBER OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE OF
LEADERSHIP CAN SEE ANYTHING IN
CLASSIFIED SITUATION.
ANY ARGUMENT THIS SHOULD BE
OFF-LIMITS ARE BONUS.
PEOPLE SHOULD READ THEM FOR
WHAT THEY ARE WHICH IS AN
ATTEMPT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE F.B.I.
IT WOULD SEEM TO PROTECT
SOMETHING THEY SIMPLY DON'T
WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW BECAUSE IT
MIGHT PROVE EMBARRASSING.
>> Jason: THAT IS THE HEART
OF IT.
I PROVES EMBARRASSING.
FROM MY VANTAGE POINT HAVING
BEEN THERE, EVERY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE SHOULD STAND BEHIND
DEVIN NUNES, TREY GOWDY, AND
JOHN RATCLIFFE AND THE
INVESTIGATORS THAT ARE GOING
IN THERE.
SENATOR GRASSLEY FOR INSTANCE.
KIM STRASSEL, A GREAT PIECE IN
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL."
SHE IS ONE OF THE BEST WRITERS